so the the Durham report one of you guys
let me read this one this is an article
from
May 16th page four so whistleblower
detail distorted and twisted FBI
weaponization claims right at the top uh
FBI special agent Garrett Boyle
whistleblower revealed the retaliation
he faced after testifying to Congress I
won't hold my breath there uh he stated
I won't hold my breath there because I'm
sure they are going to ramp up the
pressure to try to get rid of me even
more now uh oh Boyle described a
two-tiered system within the FBI
starting at the headquarters level
within which we have talked about that
as well
but it follows up with the story where
is this one here whistleblower is that
the video that says FBI whistleblower
Steve friend explains how the FBI
evolved into an intelligence agency
after 9 11 we talked about that as well
the the Durham report when it came out
it was just kind of like hey yeah cool
moved on nobody really did anything with
it
how much was in there for someone who
actually wants to do investigative
journalism to go deeper to this to hold
some people accountable because there's
a part of America that thinks you know
there are people in jail today that sold
weed 20 years ago that they're still
doing time there's people in jail today
that did a crime much smaller than what
some of these folks are doing at the top
with the different families Biden's you
know Clinton's you hear these types of
stories like how are these guys getting
away with it there was a moment where
it's like is someone going to be held
accountable so when you guys being a
former FBI agents when you read the
Durham report did you go and say to
other agents inside and say listen guys
you guys read this report what do you
think about this did you see what was
said and then if you did what was the
reaction from your peers was it like no
it's not a big deal what are you talking
about we can't even bring that up yes
did you bring it up too if you did what
was a reaction of your peers so I was
out of the FBI already after the Durham
report came out but as that
investigation was going on
James Comey mentioned how or Chris Ray I
forget one of the clips we watched where
um they implemented years ago fixes for
these things
okay well if if people of integrity and
character were running the
investigations those procedures would
have never had to be fixed anyways
because they wouldn't have been broken
for one but in my circles while I was in
the FBI everybody had the opinion that
the Russian hoax was exactly that a hoax
we knew it already before the Durham
report came out and now that that report
is out I think it's very damning of the
FBI but like you said it's it's just you
know washed over in the media nobody
really cares nobody's paying attention
unless they're digging on their own and
I think that's also problematic about
the doj and the FBI as a whole James
Comey himself refused to be interviewed
during the Durham investigation why why
you were the director of the FBI at the
time but you're not going to interview
for that and then he acts like oh I'm
not no not a big deal we already knew
all this it's that hubris that's
especially at the top but that hubris
people of that character are attracted
to the FBI for whatever reason and
it has infected the agency
yeah
I didn't I mean I was already gone when
the Durham report came out and I
unfortunately my my FBI contacts are
Garrett and the other whistleblowers of
this boy the guys I spend the majority
of my conversations with and so we have
our opinions on it but I do know from
from experience that a lot of agents are
just
that's above my pay grade I'm not even
aware of it helpless yeah well I mean
and even when we were in the hearing uh
we we had from multiple people say
people didn't even know you were
testifying in front of Congress that day
in the office they were like what you're
talking about well for it will fully
will fill ignorance what
what can that be done we see that at the
top too so last week
um Joe Murphy another assistant director
was testifying before I forget which
committee yeah and she straight up says
Eli crane I forget where he's from but
his his questioning of her is is
particularly
um poignant I think and there were some
other ones who asked her some questions
she's never read the Twitter files she's
never read the Durham report uh she's
not giving answers based on the her own
program that she's in charge of she's
not able to provide answers and she's in
charge of it and it's like of
counterintelligence I believe is what
she's at ADN and it's like that also
that willful ignorance or
maybe it's even coerced ignorance to not
pay attention to the things that are
going on in this nation when I got hired
by the FBI I thought it was going to be
a national effort where you're paying
attention to the things happening you're
you're doing your best to do what's
right no matter what but it's simply not
the case because people are
they're they're too comfortable I think
as a nation we've gotten too comfortable
it's that whole cycle of you know hard
times great Hard Men and I think we're
at a in a place where before too long
we're going to be on really hard times
are there are there more whistleblowers
you know other guys who are on the
inside that reach out to you and and are
saying hey man I want to come out but
I'm afraid you know I got a wife and
kids to take care of I got to figure out
a way to have a little bit more savings
before I do this and I don't know what
job I'm going to do after this there's
no way anybody's going to hire me are
those types of conversations being had
right now yes yes yes and and a lot of
people are actually on the inside giving
us information that we're able to come
out with so like yesterday I was able to
come out with the fact that they gave
all FBI employees three paid hours per
week for wellness
now you combine that with the three paid
hours per week for physical fitness for
wellness well mental wellness and
physical and I'm taking a break
things yes you can do yoga and color and
whatever but you could combine that with
three hours for physical fitness paid
lunch
uh FBI agents are supposed to work 50
hours a week most work 40.
um so now you're talking 11 hours out of
40 per week that they are paid to not do
their job
27.5 of the time of an FBI agent to not
investigate why would somebody leave
that shop then correct right okay so
you're saying so you're saying what
you're doing right now is you are the
chief Recruiting office for FBI they
just got 17 000 applications right I'm
going to yeah Hey listen I I heard you
guys are paying well and you don't
expect me to work that's awesome I'm in
right yeah I want that job when it comes
to FBI salary what's a starting mid top
level expectation of what uh and salary
and benefits of what you receive being
an FBI agent so you it's the GS pay
scale you start as a 10-1 but you also
get availability pay which is a 25 bump
in pay so uh talk numbers so it's about
uh 70. yeah as a 10 one yeah that's that
looks about right and then you're at
about 78 Grand right that's where you
start yeah and then after five years you
get promoted to gs13 step one and so you
get the law enforcement availability pay
which is 25 bump this is Agent salary
it's different for the other positions
but
um and then depending on where you live
you get locality pay so one of the
smears they've put out against us is oh
well they're paid hacks from cash Patel
okay go ahead and say that that he paid
us money right before Christmas from his
foundation
um because we had been suspended without
pay already and our whistleblower
activities had already happened the
retaliation had already happened
where I was headed to Virginia I was
going to be making about 132 000 a year
because I would have hit my GS 13 uh
coming up here in like another month or
so and
um
why would you give that up and the South
the benefits the salary of the job it is
one of those reviews on Yelp oh it looks
like such a cool job yeah it was it was
a great job Steve and I were both SWAT
guys uh which added an extra element of
of you know service and but also like a
more fun aspect instead of sitting in
the office all the time like instead of
being a nerd like Steve yeah okay you
get the cool guy Factor yeah yeah yeah
and yeah and so you know the new unit I
was heading to I was really excited
about uh what what I was going to be
doing there and
but so yeah for people to say oh they're
just grifters and paid hacks and all
this like not further from the truth and
um but yeah I I've told my wife just
read because all of this you know we
were we're probably getting to a point
where we were
uh the callus was forming over a lot of
what has happened and and now in a very
public way it's
um it's all back you know and I'm
talking about it every day which is is
fine I hope that is a part of the
healing process for me but
um this journey has not been easy and if
I could pick Snap My Fingers yeah I
would be making my 130 000 salary and I
would be more or less an anonymous FBI
agent I don't think I really look like
an FBI agent so I blend in well and
um we were comfortable you know but
um now everybody knows that face that
beard that hair cover of GQ out here but
getting outside your comfort zone is is
also a good thing and
I never thought my belief in that would
lead me into something like this but um
as as strange it is as it is to say and
probably to hear I'm grateful uh that
you know the Lord has put this
opportunity in front of me because
I can only go forward and and hopefully
glorify him in the process
that's awesome I will say that you do
have the Adam Sandler Zohan look though
I don't know I know that look that's a
legit look I can't get it out of my head
right now that's all I'm thinking about
with the hair doing all this we got a
Few Good Men and we got this off yeah
you want to just show the picture I mean
there is an element of a little bit of
Zohan stuff going on there it's a good
looking guy so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
thank you
foreign